our lady is going tonight concerns drugs
you know the substances that gave us
most music Seasons one and two of The
West Wing and this spectacular clip of
the BBC reporter getting inadvertently
wasted burning behind me is eight and a
half tons of heroin opium passion other
narcotics
that is a clip from the award
winning Last Week Tonight with John
Oliver The Late Night series is now in
its 10th season it has won 14 Emmys wow
yes the show takes a close look at big
topics like artificial intelligence
solitary confinement and even
psychedelic assisted therapy using
comedy and a whole lot of research and
John Oliver is here with us this morning
John good morning good morning it is
lovely to be in Times Square so
universally agreed upon him in the
universe
and we were talking about you coming on
and Chandler our producer said you know
it takes about six weeks for the
producers and the writers and everybody
on the staff to put together one of
those segments we said no wait yeah Gail
Chandler you said six weeks not six days
and then Vlad goes uh I can attest yeah
I was going to say yeah so that comes
across as a bit of it in soccer it
doesn't you're telling me they don't
turn up think of something and then
basically say it in real time no it's a
month and a half oh John I was surprised
because there are many nights that
Marion is up till two o'clock morning
doing research exactly you of anyone
cannot be surprised by yes we'll talk
about Marion in just a second but I was
surprised John that it was six weeks
okay okay yeah we do work really hard
I guess the thing is with some of the
stories they're either so complicated or
so legally volatile that uh if we get
something wrong either the story
collapses or we're gone forever but what
Vlad pointed out that I thought was
really genius is that you get all the
research you get all the facts and then
there's a comedy team that writes it
it's along with your your talent yeah
because you can't you call it little
jokes you don't want to build jokes on
sound right because then right that's
what we learned gradually if a whole
bunch of research comes in and just
wipes away a whole bunch of jokes of the
writers have uh written and that feels
like the process isn't working so yeah
we shifted things so how do you pick the
topics we get told everyone can pitch at
the show so it's basically whatever
we're drawn to if if it gives us a sense
that there's something interesting there
that's something that's worth spending
six whole weeks on as crazy as that
sounds Gail yeah and if we show people
things they haven't seen before that's
one of the metrics that we use if we can
uh give people something that's uh
perhaps new to them I know but that's
what fascinates me about the show
because last Sunday it was about Farm
Workers yeah no Farm Workers out
honestly like honestly
exactly and then I started watching it
John and it was so interesting yes all
the things you don't know so I'm glad
you liked it yeah that is why we don't
ever say but this is what we're going to
be doing this week because it would
sound like a show that you didn't want
to watch right so it's like a closely
guarded synchronous what we're going to
talk about each week not because it's
going to be fun but because it's better
for us to have a captive audience who
can't leave well one of the reasons I
tuned in is because this particular week
I watch you all the time but I said I
know they're going to say something
about Donald Trump in the indictment I
can't wait to see his take on it and you
didn't really go into it I was surprised
how come it was the end of the week it
felt like that story had been talked
about okay to death all right uh so yeah
we uh we kind of I can't remember what
we talked about instead but it was more
fun than trying to no it was it was and
even the title of the show when it first
started Last Week Tonight ago how is
that you were thinking about it right
what does that mean and now that we know
how the show works yeah it's actually
very good John Oliver I guess it worked
out I guess that was the problem with
that was having to create a Show's title
before you know what the show is going
to be yeah so yeah it was a slight play
on words I love that you all have
hilarious stunts number one I love
anything with Times Square and singing
and dancing
a giant cake do you have a favorite when
you look at those that's Times Square
thing was genius I love the Bob Murray
one that's right exactly this is great
this was the end of a multi-years-long
um with a coal Baron and this was us
winning the lawsuit and celebrating
celebrating in you might say a
relatively provocative fashion telling
him to eat something this is also a
media company standing by you as you
face lawsuits that uh yes could have
been uh well it was very very it was
yeah it was very very important to me
obviously that HBO did stand by us
because what he was engaging with was a
slap suit he'd use those against all
manner of local uh newspapers who cannot
afford uh to fight back so it felt like
when he's when you're working for a
company that can't afford to fight back
you must and we did so John I have to
say thank you to you and the staff to
Liz to Tim to everybody on the staff
because and Marion told me not to
embarrass you she's like please don't
embarrass John and don't embarrass me
but I won't I'll just show you this
little uh picture that we have of our
daughter Celine wearing Last Week
Tonight onesies
um and we thank you and go our staff I
hope you gave something else besides the
onesie they did Gail they did I mean
John you're so generous of Lindsay
what's your name on it you're a Vlad we
gave her a whole bunch of Seth
[Laughter]
uh time shares which you say lying is a
strategy or pumpkin spice lattes which
you say you'd rather drink a cable knit
spider uh I would say I would say that
time she has it worst I I I promise it
technically Ends by the time you get to
the bottom of it a timeshare is for life
all right homeowners associations are
artificial intelligence uh artificial
statistics we don't know exactly where
that's going home associations are a
living nightmare 19 000 1900 interest
those homeowner associations yes uh
payday loans or the lottery now I was
struck by the lottery people spend more
on the NFL video games movie tickets MLB
yes and porn combined well done that's
what you told me hitting the emphasis
hard on the end oh that's my information
okay uh I I would say that the lottery
is empty hope payday loans are a bear
trap okay New Year's Eve would you say
uh it's the three worst things people
that you can't stand yes staring at Ryan
Seacrest and getting drunk or
or the movie Air Bud which you release
as a web special you attack this poor
dog who wanted to play basketball in a
web only special
I would I would dispute whether we
attacked that dog food I think we
celebrated that dog to the extent they
deserved to be celebrated Which is less
than it is
I love it
John
thank elations on 10 season
death that's okay yeah it's like it's
like the old snake that's our new town
Last Week Tonight Sunday night on HBO
John Oliver look at the gray I love it